the 2016 election or as it's commonly
known a horrifying glimpse at Satan's
Pinterest boards 2016 this week was the
Democratic National Convention and after
the bizarre Republican circus that
preceded it all they really had to do
was not appear like a complete disaster
and yet somehow
good evening their party's chairman off
the program an apparent Russian email
hack and that will revolt among Bernie
Sanders supporters welcome to day one of
the Democratic National Convention that
was day one day one
the DNC got off to the roughest start
that I've seen since Fox fives 2011
coverage of the San Diego Boat Show good
morning everybody I'm hanging out with
my friend John Fox 5 Morning News starts
look over there and it starts right now
[Applause]
that is basically what happened on day 1
of the DNC in a nutshell because because
before debbie Wasserman Schultz could
even gavel in the convention a leaked
email scandal had forced her to resign
and Bernie Sanders supporters gave her a
rough reception when she met with her
own States delegation I'm sorry
disruptive borderline unhinged and
getting ready to vote that is literally
the only Florida that we know the only
way that could be anymore Florida is if
one of the Bernie delegates was an aging
heavily armed racist alligator now
luckily for the Democrats things
gradually got back on track thanks to a
series of stirring speeches beginning
with the first lady today I wake up
every morning in a house that was built
by slaves
and and I watched my daughter's too
beautiful intelligent black young women
playing with their dogs on the White
House lawn
now whatever your party affiliation that
is a truly moving speech the only thing
I would say to the audience is maybe
don't start your round of applause
directly following the phrase built by
slaves oh they did a lovely job they had
to they had to do a good job they they
had to that's why
lovely now the next day it was Bill
Clinton's turn to fire up the crowd
retelling his relationship with Hillary
seemingly in real time and then
Wednesday on Wednesday Joe Biden spoke
assuming the role of America's
motivational cattle-prod
we are America second to none and we own
the finish line don't forget it god
bless you all
may God protect our troops
come on once he has left the White House
Biden is going to be the most inspiring
soul cycle instructor ever come on
bundle you own the finish line come on
don't you like the way Biden was
actually the warm-up man for the
president who like many speakers
throughout the week occasionally lapsed
into a tone of actual disbelief at what
America might be considering doing this
election people outside of the United
States do not understand what's going on
in this election
they really don't that's actually true
the rest of the world does not
understand Trump's candidacy any more
than they understand the menu at Guy
Fieri's American kitchen this a donkey
saucer is it made from actual donkey why
do you do this to yourself
but the emotional highlight of the
convention was undoubtedly a speech by
Kaiser comm a lawyer immigrant and
father of a fallen Muslim American
soldier Donald Trump you're asking
Americans to trust you with their future
let me ask you have you even read the
United States Constitution
I will
I will gladly lend you
oh that is an American founding
document being inspirationally used as a
middle finger and it wasn't even the
most devastating part of mr. Karnes
speech have you ever been to Arlington
Cemetery go look at the graves of brave
Patriots who died defending United
States of America you will see all
faiths genders and ethnicities you have
sacrificed nothing Wow
that engendered in me a level of emotion
that I did not think was possible after
16 months of this depressing campaign
and 39 years on earth as a British
person and yet the true theories however
incredible the surrogate speeches are
conventions are really judged by the
performances of the two people on the
party's ticket so how did they fare well
let's start with Tim Kaine a human
sweater vest he's he's basically the
portrait of a vice president that came
with the frame his speech his speech is
exactly as boring as you would expect
with the exception of his almost
impressively bad Trump impression it's
going to be great believe me
we're gonna build a wall and make Mexico
pay for it believe me we're gonna
destroy Isis so fast believe me what the
was that that doesn't sound like
him at all how is this man gonna win an
election if he couldn't even win a game
of cranium is it Jackie Gleason Brad
Garrett kicked him just mold whoever it
is out of clay we have no chance here
and as for Hillary Clinton on the night
of her historic nomination she stood
before the nation in full pitbull
cosplay she had a genuinely stupid
amount of balloons dropped on her head
and in between delivered a speech
focusing on the actual job requirements
of being president I sweat the details
of policy whether we're talking about
the exact level of lead and the drinking
water in Flint Michigan the number of
mental health facilities in Iowa or the
cost of your prescription drugs because
it's not just a detail if it's your kid
if it's your family it's a big deal it
was a kind of interesting approach
instead of soaring rhetoric the bulk of
her speech was basically I'm gonna
micromanage the out of this office
I'm gonna get granular as now drop
the balloons and I will count them all
I'm all about the details it was
definitely a restrained speech to close
a convention especially when you compare
it to the week before when Donald Trump
essentially opened his mouth and exhaled
a swarm of locusts but now that both
conventions are behind us maybe we
should try and take stock of what they
have taught us about the current state
of our two political parties the DNC
showed the Democrats to be a coalition
of constantly squabbling if
fundamentally like-minded Katy Perry
fans and as for the RNC it showed that
the Republican Party doesn't seem to
currently exist because to all intents
and purposes we didn't really get a
Republican convention this year
sure there was a cleveland-based
gathering of delegates featuring all of
Donald Trump's favorite family members
and Tiffani and celebrities whose most
notable upcoming projects include the
Emmy Awards in memoriam reel probably
but but almost everything that you would
expect from a GOP convention was absent
many prominent Republicans chose to skip
it as did both living Republican former
presidents and for the party of Reagan
the tongue was unusually and
relentlessly negative not only have our
citizens endured domestic disaster but
they've lived through one international
humiliation after another one after
another what is he even talking about
only one major international humiliation
from recent history comes to mind and
it's the ones standing behind that
podium wide open to pick up the mantle
of people who actually like living here
don't let anyone ever tell you that this
country isn't great that somehow we need
to make it bring it again because this
right now is the greatest country on
Earth
yes the greatest country on Earth you
hear that Denmark
you got Ilsa yeah I don't care what the
world's happiness index says Michelle
Obama told me that we're number one and
her arms make me feel safe
so unusually the DNC felt like the more
patriotic occasion it featured America's
greatest actress dressed up like a
plastic tablecloth from the 4th of July
and General John Allen's screaming at
people to our enemies we will pursue you
as only America can you will fear us and
to Isis and others we will defeat you
who who were you shouting at Isis is not
watching the DNC they're watching
Braxton Family Values
it's Thursday fool but but that is think
about it that is a retired four-star
Marine general threatening vaguely
defined enemies while a crowd wave signs
reading USA that is not something you
expect to see and a Democratic
convention not because Democrats aren't
patriotic but because Republicans have
always done that louder and longer this
whole two weeks felt topsy-turvy it's
frankly no wonder that commentators felt
a little confused but if you were a
Martian and you came down and looked at
these two conventions and somebody asked
you which of the two parties is the most
overtly patriotic yeah you would say the
Democratic Party okay but if you were a
Martian who landed on Earth and someone
asked you which party seemed more
patriotic you would probably say wait
that's your question
I'm literally an alien is that nothing
else you want to ask me how was your
trip for example or what was tilda
swinton like as a kid usually I'm at
like usually people's first question for
me is why is your penis made of pure
glowing white light but the reason the
Republican Party essentially forgot to
celebrate America this year might be
because they were too busy celebrating
Donald Trump's claims that he would fix
whatever Donald Trump thinks is wrong
with America nobody knows the system
better than me
[Applause]
which is why I alone can fix it when I
take the oath of office next year I will
restore law and order to our country
I am your voice now now I am your voice
is actually a fair claim he does speak
for some people although you were kind
of hope that they would then react the
way most people do when they hear their
own voice which is to say oh I
don't actually sound like that do I
that is King a horrified the RNC taught
us that a party which used to be
organized around a set of shared
principles is currently organized around
one man and given that that is the case
his judgment is pretty much the only
thing that is important when considering
who to vote for in November so to that
end I would like to show you something
he said recently and before I do he has
clearly said countless awful things
throughout this campaign any of which
would disqualify any other candidate
just this week he declined yet again to
release his tax returns lies about
getting a letter from the NFL agreeing
with him that the debate shouldn't clash
with football games called Angela Merkel
and employed that Brazil brought
the Zika virus on themselves and
encouraged a foreign powers hack of his
political rival now two of those didn't
happen but you're not sure which two and
that's kind of the point isn't it
because Trump hasn't said one crazy
thing he said thousands of crazy things
each of which blunts the effect of the
others it's the bed of dales principle
if you step on one nail it hurts you if
you step on a thousand nails no single
one stands out and you're fine that is
how Donald Trump has managed to say
pretty much anything in this campaign
seemingly without consequences and yet
even with that caveat his response when
asked about that speech from Kizza Khan
stands out I saw him he was you know
very emotional and probably look like a
nice guy to me his wife
if you look at his wife she was standing
there she had nothing to say she
probably maybe she wasn't allowed to
have anything to say you tell me but
plenty of people have written that she
she was extremely quiet and it looked
like she had nothing to say okay for a
start his wife has explained that she
chose not to speak because she gets too
upset when she sees images of her dead
son's face you but I'm sorry I'm
sorry
please continue he said you have
sacrificed nothing and no one
well that sounds who wrote that did
Hilary's scriptwriters write it how
would you answer that father what
sacrifice have you made for your country
I think I made a lot of sacrifices I
worked very very hard I've created
thousands and thousands of jobs tens of
thousands of jobs built great structures
I've done I've had I've had tremendous
success I think those are sacrifices oh
sure I think they're sacrifices no no
absolutely not
they are self-serving half-truths from a
self-serving half man who has somehow
convinced half the country that
sacrifice is the same thing as success
honestly the main takeaway from these
two weeks is that incredibly we may be
on the brink of electing such a damaged
sociopathic narcissist that the simple
presidential duty of comforting the
families of fallen soldiers may actually
be beyond his capabilities and I
genuinely did not think that that was a
part of the job that someone could be
bad at and now this and finally this
week some more highlights from the
Democratic National Convention
to hell with Trump's American Nightmare
we believe in the American dream
the right-wing has thrown everything at
Hillary not only the kitchen sink
not only the stove but the refrigerator
and the toaster stood for the macro
issues and those macaroni and cheese
issues put down your pokemons go for
just a second her name and Donald Trump
do our dirty dozen list dirty dangerous
denying Donald shade boy and it's true I
haven't really got the bolo tie look to
catch on she was the first person to
call me when my second child was born I
heard no it says about my family but
Hillary on oh she loves HGTV and she can
devour buffalo wings whether on a car
plane or train
[Applause]
it's healing time it's hope time is
Hildred time it's healing time is hope
time it's hildreth time it
in several times
is home time if his room time is healing
time is her
[Music]
you better listen to me I said she will
stay cold
[Applause]